[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link joining us today at the round
table of dim lighting is youtuber
vlogger filmmaker producer actress and
comedian Anna Akana and as a
jack-of-all-trades content creator she
writes directs and stars in her
productions which are some of the
highest quality produced videos on
youtube the special effects in her short
films are impressive and the costumes
look like something you see on a sci-fi
channel series just take a look at the
short films like Miss Earth here she is
and of course one of the most popular
web series out there Riley rewind which
she both wrote and starred in she also
has made a name for herself with her
polished comedic vlogs on her channel
that are one of the coolest combinations
of vlogging and sketch comedy that we've
seen here's a clip from one called
types of toxic friends we've all had or
been toxic friends at one point or
another in our lives but sometimes it
takes you a while to recognize who they
are or when you're being one
there's the copycat do you like my new
outfit I mean I guess it looks a little
bit like yours it's exactly the same are
you copying are you copying me
the Negative Nancy I can't believe I got
that promotion so much extra
responsibility is so much stress a
social climber I heard you like friends
like a famous person can we be friends I
like jogging to have if you have a toxic
friend in your life and talking things
out just isn't gonna work then break it
off pull the plug nothing healthy is
gonna come from that relationship do it
right now do it right now
I'll do it right now Anna's also known
of her involvement in the suicide
prevention community due to the very
unfortunate loss of her sister in 2007
she really opened up about it in her
emotional youtube video called please
don't kill yourself in 2013 she received
a lot of positive feedback from the
video and quickly became an inspiring
voice for suicide prevention here's a
clip and I'm getting a lot of questions
from people on the Internet of like I
want to kill myself what should I do if
you commit serious
I I don't even know like I don't even
know what would happen to you all I
really know is what happens to the
people around you after you die I think
he'll be really really hard for your
family to live normally we appreciated
Anna's willingness to talk candidly in
this biscuit about her sister suicide
and how it made her who he/she is today
her past relationship with
raywilliamjohnson and what it's like to
be one half of a youtube power couple
her vow to be single for a year and how
that really didn't pan out and the many
creative projects that she's juggling
right now we know you're gonna enjoy our
conversation with Anna but first we want
to mention our sponsor EF college break
POF college what EF College Break they
make travel easy affordable and even
more fun for anyone ages 18 to 28
college not required you know traveling
around the world one of the most
exciting things you can do especially
when you are young but it is
logistically difficult to travel right
to get the most rewarding experience
takes a lot of planning you got a book
flights lodging transportation when
you're there you got to figure out where
to go what to see when to see it it's a
lot of work and you have to do it all on
your own or you could let the EF College
break expert travelers do all of that
for you why let them do it
because this their job and they are pros
they can take care of booking flights
lodging transportation while you're
there site and event coordination and
provide you with a tour director who is
a local expert
they built group trips across six
continents with everything from trekking
Machu Picchu cruising the Greek Isles
and getting acquainted with Thailand and
almost half a college break travelers
sign up solo so even if you sign it by
yourself you will not be alone on your
trip not only are you gonna have an
amazing experience in a new place or new
places all over the world but you're
gonna be meeting new people making
lifelong friends by sharing those
experiences with them it doesn't have to
be intimidating to plan a trip outside
of the country an EF college break makes
it possible I'm looking on the site
right now how does this sound a tenday
Costa Rican advance
sure oh and I love Costa Rica there's
wood down there I bring back bowls for
people like Linc
how about an eight day escape to London
and Perry sounds good or a ten day grand
tour of Spain the world is out there
it's waiting to be explored and the
planning's already been done yes head
over to our special URL great way to
support the show and enrich your own
life go to EF college break comm slash
rhett and Link and we'll hook you up
with an extra $100 off your next
adventure that's right $100 off using EF
college break com slash rhett and Link
and now onto the biscuit the first time
we met maybe and maybe the last time we
saw each other yeah because when you
showed up just a few minutes ago you
mention it as if the last time we saw
each other and I was thinking first time
it's Julianne Smith's birthday party
cool party he's not a small private
party you and Ray were there this is
this is it was a year ago no it might
have been it wasn't three was I two
years two years ago and first thing you
said to us was I love your Star Trek
middle school musical which just came
out it like been out less than a week
and it wasn't doing well it wasn't it
wasn't one of our in it never became one
of our more popular middle school
musicals we did Breaking Bad after that
which was a lot more successful so I was
kind of disappointed but I immediately
liked you as a person I like you as a
creator I know some of your work but
yeah Oh compliment right off the bat
yeah it's easy to like people who like
you and if you like my stuff especially
stuff that people aren't liking I'm like
oh she's great oh and I has always been
great because you push the right button
on that one even if you weren't even
being sincere
you could tell me I love that you guys
make so much like high-quality legit
production value stuff I really
appreciate and admire that and plus Star
Trek it was that your jam or something
no I don't I didn't even like Star Trek
but I watched it and I was like now I
get the appeal of Star Trek and it's
like more entertaining because kids are
singing to me interesting that you okay
so what
you're obviously into sci-fi and stuff
because you're you like to put people
into costumes that look like they're
from Star Wars so are you a Star Wars
girl
I'll Begley like Star Wars that was all
like a little bit before my time so I'm
more into like dystopian why a novels
and okay that whole Jam got it yeah just
dope you what dystopian young adult oh
why a no yes why I novels okay
the yah novels I don't even know what
the word dystopia means you it's the in
it's the Armageddon man you know
antithesis of you taupe when things hit
the fan man oh well then I dunno what it
is I just didn't know that's what that
meant well welcome to 2015 I'm listen
I'm setting the stage to be totally open
and honest here and if anyone that
doesn't know what any words mean besides
me feel free at any point to say that
but are so dystopian why a novels what
what are these what do these do to the
psyche well what's what why does it
resonate with you um I like speculative
fiction
I like imagining what the future is
gonna be like what kind of class systems
we have what our monetary systems are
like and with why a novels in particular
you get like that that like a really
cute love story with it so I'm like a
boy sorry are you hopeful about the
future or do you think it is it we are
gonna be in a dystopian future I think
it'll be kind of the same as now where
there's a lot of happening but it's
still a pretty nice place to live are
you a prepper
no I should be you're know you're out
you're a prep prepper I'm not prepped
for the earthquakes but but you're
prepping to prep yeah I like mentally
tell myself oh I should get more water
like Oprah's apparently busing in water
because of the drought I was like I
should do that you need water yeah we
all need water no what you need is a
friend who is a prepper or an aspiring
prepper and then he'll buy stuff for you
I do have a friend who's a prepper he
built this property out in the desert
and has like guns and like water and so
really yes and I said he because I was
referring to Rhett Oh do you have a he
to it could have been a she yeah I have
a he what's his first name
I don't want to say you don't even want
to say his first name
of that desert compound because we'll be
there as soon as the big one hits why
can't you say his first name he might
listen to this say a name is not his
first name and we'll talk to him as if
he's that guy well say his name is Ben
okay Ben is out in the desert he's got
guns he's got water it's so prepper to
like not even give out your real name I
love it like that's perfect
he probably doesn't even give you his
real name well he's a known figure so I
don't wanna oh we're getting closer now
the compound is just happy just bought
it oh it's a bug-out location yeah so
he's an actor no but in the industry yes
okay we're getting closer
see you don't dangle stuff like this for
me on any or biscuit because I cannot
let it go first of all links gonna be at
my house okay I mean that's what's gonna
happen with him and I'm probably gonna
be at my bug-out location that he
doesn't know about you know I mean I'm
gonna bug out to my location and Lane
it's gonna be at my home with the stuff
that you live no way I'm staying in the
valley in the middle of it oh the city
would be the worst place gotta get out
have you seen not been it's a bunker I
have not I just know that it was
purchased and where it is see a
conspiracy theorist or is he just he's a
little mentally unstable he's a director
maybe yep it mentally unstable equals
director okay but it's interesting that
you know about it that means that you're
invited I am I am invited to see the
bunker should things ever go down that's
a you know what you're way ahead of me
did the invitation come with like you
take it out and it's what is this like
little vellum piece of paper P on it and
then you see what it's written no it's
all verbal nothing can be recorded or
ran down except on a podcast so we met
that day and we haven't seen each other
since but I mean I've you know I've seen
your work and felt like I've gotten to
know you more since that point I just
wonder why our paths haven't crossed
since then it seems weird that our first
meeting was our last over two years ago
I don't hang out with a lot of people
who do stuff online like I don't even
know how to meet those people because
everyone's always like in their studio
or in their home
like I'll see people in passing at
VidCon but that's about it yeah we keep
our head down you're super busy I mean
you've got so many different things
you're doing and I mean we're gonna get
into many of those over the course this
conversation but of all the things and I
saw like you gave a glimpse of your
calendar and like a recent vlog it was
all color-coded you got some OCD
happening I like a little bit of
synesthesia where like I associate
colors with like numbers or specific
ideas lien doesn't know what dystopia
means he's not I don't know what that
means yeah actually I didn't know
everything about that there you go
but you know your your calendar is like
so full of stuff going from this this
pilot audition to recording the podcast
I tried to pause it to see if we were on
there mm-hmm like I couldn't look that
closely to calendar but it felt
stalkerish so I stopped but what do you
I mean what are you most excited about
at this point with so many things you're
juggling I'm excited to make a movie I
want to make a movie this year I want to
so it's not even something that are you
writing it or it's just aspirational
it's like the next thing it's the next
thing it's a it's something that my
former assistant wrote called wedding
wreckers and it's very funny two female
comedians are the stars and it's very
sharp very rated-r and so I told her I
wanted to produce that so right now I'm
and legal with like optioning it and
going out for financing and developing
is that one of the reasons that you've
been on the short film kick lately like
trying to you know you're doing a
different thing on YouTube you're doing
something that not a lot of people are
doing you're making short films looking
actual short films is that in
preparation for like oh I'm gonna do a
feature yeah I wanted to do a feature
I'd say three years ago but I was like
I'm nowhere near ready for that so I'll
make as many short films as I can until
that feature comes out and we're talking
as a director and talent or not just
directed I've directed all of them yeah
but the film you're you're gonna direct
the film
no for my first film I want to act and
learning from the short films directing
and acting are completely different
sides of the brain and so and I'm much
more geared towards being like OCD and
analytical and
very much in that space so if I do
direct my acting suffers if I'm doing
both at the same time mm-hmm
got it so tell us about the the short
film commitment that you kind of made
either to yourself or to your audience
there was like a number involved right
yeah in the beginning of 2014 I said I
was gonna do 12 so I was aiming for one
a month and I was like I don't know how
realistic that is because I've never
made a short film and I only did six for
the whole year but I also went through
like a big breakup and like moving and
so that sent me that felt like two three
months behind and so this year I'm
working on another one but I told my
audience I'm gonna take my time with
this one because last time it would be
like pre-production for one while I'm
also editing the second one while I'm
also you know in development for the
third one
so everything was happening at the same
time and so I'd like to see what I can
do if I really take my time with
something that's maybe 20 to 30 minutes
long what and then you did is the most
recent one miss earth is that the last
big short film and that one was over 13
minutes long that was a and it had a lot
going on yeah I mean that was a pretty
major endeavor yeah that was the most
stressful experience of my life yeah
yeah directing acting producing I lost
some friends over it I invested my life
savings into it it was a very good
learning experience awesome friends tell
us about that what did whose fault was
that I think it was just
miscommunication and like like
expectation set like I'm very paranoid
about treating crew really well and like
paying the day of and I almost have this
tendency like as a you know just as a
female and also like someone who's
always eager to please like going around
and making sure everyone's okay and I'd
worked with the same crew the entire
year and so at this point I was much
more and I like cold but I wasn't as
like serving to people and like checking
in and two of my best friends thought I
was a quote/unquote [ __ ] and I was like
while I'm doing three jobs and this is
the biggest thing of my life so far and
it's my life savings and you're not
doing your job so I need to scold you
about it and that kind of led into a big
fallout so I had to learn a lot of
lessons about having friends on set and
also being a boss and when to
differentiate those two things so they
stayed on set and did their job but they
didn't remain friends no
how did it it ended on the very last day
in the very last ten minutes of of the
shoot yeah was it whether emotional
explosions in via yeah it was really bad
like did spit fly or tears fall or what
um I cried and said a couple times
during it but in that last 10 minutes
yeah it was me and my former DP
screaming at each other and I was like
this conversations over
like we're trying to wrap and get out of
the studio I not talking about this
anymore like people love it when
everyone's waiting for the director to
like call it's a wrap yeah and you're
like Marty this is a bad time yeah
exactly and I was not everyone is
standing around made up like aliens all
watching this happen no it's gotta be a
little weird yeah it was it was very
awkward it was it was a very awkward
time in my life so what what else did
you what you said you learned some
things too so what'd you learn yeah I
learned that you know ultimately it's
about the project and a lot of the times
I want to cultivate a really good work
environment and I want to serve people
in the sense of making sure everyone's
comfortable and taken care of but I also
have to make sure I'm taking care of
myself and I'm taking care of my project
because it's all self-financed and so I
learned a lot about being a boss people
said so no one that's listening now is
ever gonna work for you it's all about
the products you totally switch no I
didn't switch completely but I have to
know what to put first you know like and
I had a really good convo with my dad
where he was like never changed the way
you work cuz I think it's great that you
try so hard to make it the best for
everyone and I've done like I've done
grip and I've done sound and I've tried
to do camera op and like do every job on
a set so that I know how to make that
person's job easier and like know how to
be a better director but at the same
time I'm always like Oh am I being a
[ __ ] or like is this unreasonable and I
think I need to stop that more often
before it gets out of hand are you a
perfectionist I used to be not so much
anymore now it's like just do the best
you can do the best you can you
mentioned your dad we want to we want to
find out about you people your fame
where you're from were we born Monterey
California and then I moved every two to
three years of my life till today I
moved I'm a military scenario Oh dad's
Marine Corps Marine Corps so like major
dad the old television show McCraney and
I'm your dad and I come home and wasn't
this gonna be a funny sitcom because I'm
a drill sergeant there's your dad does
your dad have just a mustache
no he had a beard most of the time a
flattop I don't know what a flattop is
over the Marine haircut where the hair
is goes up and then it's just flat oh no
I've never heard it used to have one
middle school yeah wow that's sad when
you get a flattop at the barber they
give you a special brush to take home
what yeah because a commemorative brush
right at the top where it you know hits
your the top of your Scout it sits like
this standing up it's like that tall but
in order to be flat it's got to be a
little bit taller on the sides as it
goes out and so they give you this brush
to take and go over the corners to keep
it up Rudolph Blanchard any air cut that
needs a special brush you just didn't
get like well I don't have it anymore
so you moved around a lot as a kid you
said every few months every few years so
Monterey where else I've lived in Japan
Hawaii Korea over thirteen states Wow
yeah I had a group in the south no I
grew but like I had a North Carolina
accent for like a long time really yeah
okay that's what we have oh yeah yeah
where are you guys Carolina are you yes
I thought you were saying that because
you're like as a point of reference but
yeah North Carolina so you had a North
Carolina accent yeah I grew up and when
I was living at a talk I was in North
Carolina
what part fatal tree point it's a Cherry
Point okay guys how did Jacksonville
yeah so it was interesting to be like
this little Asian person with a with an
accident well that part of North
Carolina is pretty distinct mm-hmm
that's eastern North Carolina
if I in fact interesting is you
mentioned that because I won't I won't
mention names but somebody that we know
his sister who grew up in California
just moved to Cherry Point with her
military husband and I was asking him
how are they because they moved from San
Clemente awesome beach town California
and I know what Cherry Point is like so
how they do anything was like she cries
every day you know it's a I mean nothing
is on Cherry Point right now it's just
different you go from you go from this
you know amazing beach town to a
military town and Eastern North Carolina
that's not easy I mean did it did that
lifestyle growing up did that prove to
be challenging for you it's I have
habits that I shouldn't have like I I'm
ihrer people a lot like if I want to fit
in or I want people to like me I just
mirror their body language and their
speech I do it like a lot really
subconsciously or all like chameleon my
personality to kind of match theirs or
be complimentary so it's it's had a lot
of identity issues growing up I'm like
wait what am I really like if I'm not
influenced by people I'm around did you
experience any racism in the south yeah
yeah I remember I moved and someone was
like go back to town or drink and I was
like I was born here so it was weird so
you didn't have a volatile response to
that you just tried to explain yourself
yeah I mean I always felt white inside I
didn't really realize I was in minority
told much much later in life so that was
like oh oh that's weird right
I felt white inside so when was the
realization probably like when I was 8
and me and my friends were playing like
Spice Girl dress up and like I wasn't
allowed to be any of the Spice Girls so
I was like oh that's oh that's
interesting right because it wasn't
there wood there was no I never thought
about that yeah I knew something was
missing and where's your mom from my
mom's from the Philippines okay
and was she and did they meet in the
Philippines so this was her
her first time in the US when she came
with your dad yeah her and my dad dated
long-distance for like two years and
they moved her out here and they got
married and she was pregnant with me and
so did you what was your I know a lot of
times the friends your friends can
especially in the south I've noticed
this if your mom is different then your
friends will ask questions and they kind
of see that oh [ __ ] your mom talks
different your mom cooks food
differently or whatever did you
experience any of that ah no my mom's
always been like the very much the life
of the party so people like her quite a
bit when when they meet her and they're
never like off-put she'll just be like
yeah I've eaten dog before and people
are like what that's crazy you I have
not I've not eaten dog she didn't she
didn't she didn't bring that dish no
that was only when she was dirt poor and
apparently like their family was
starving yeah I can understand it yeah I
know that part of your story is just the
harrowing experience of your your sister
passing away so I wanted to talk about
that how many siblings do you have I
have a brother he's younger younger -
mm-hmm or about or each like two three
years apart okay yeah so he was next and
then your sister was the youngest of
three yes okay tell us about that uh
well it was she was
I always think she was bipolar or had
some kind of mood disorder she was very
manic depressive but I also don't know
if that's just because she was like a 13
year old girl going through puberty but
she committed suicide in like 2007 right
around the time all the cyber bullying
was kind of happening
she got threatened by a bunch of guys at
her school that they were gonna beat her
up and so she brought a BB gun to
protect herself because she had told her
teacher and her teacher didn't say
anything and this is before like all
those suicides started happening so
bullying wasn't something really on our
social radar and she got expelled from
school for bringing that BB gun and kind
of like spiraled into this depression
and eventually killed herself how close
were you we were pretty close I mean we
would fight as much as we would
friends just like with his typical
sisters that's that's what you gotta do
yeah it's like something you sign to say
yes I will be a good sister yeah we will
fight so I I get that I mean do you
remember finding out like how you found
out yeah it was a Valentine's Day and
she had fought with like every member of
our family and then had come to me and
we fought and it was so weird cuz like
the last thing I ever said to her was
like I hate you like go away and then I
went to the park with my boyfriend at
the time to like surprise him with a
picnic and then there were like fire
trucks and like ambulances going by at
one point and like we didn't think
anything of it but then I got like this
really like weird feeling and it's the
only time I've been like maybe I'm
psychic because maniacally I was just
like we have to go but there's something
really wrong we have to go and so we
packed up the picnic and my brother
called me while we were packing up and
he was like what I'm about to say is
gonna change your life forever Christina
tried to kill herself and so we got home
and paramedics were like leading her out
and I remember they were like joking
about something and like what did she
what did she do
oh she hung herself in the closet with
like one of her scarves yeah and my
brother had only found out because she
was playing this same song on repeat
like at the loudest volume ever in her
room and so finally he came in to be
like can you please shut that off and
then he couldn't find her and then he
found her in the closet so it's always
been like oh man like my brother
definitely had the hardest job being the
one to find her but she had been dead I
guess for something like 15 minutes so
they couldn't bring her back and even if
they could they said she would have
suffered intense brain damage so we as
you showed up as they were wheeling her
out yeah at that time you didn't know
whether it was it was she had actually
died because you said your brother said
she attempted it yes yeah we all kind of
thought it would be okay cuz they put
like the breathing masks over her so I
thought she was gonna be okay but my dad
knew based on like trying to give her
CPR and like her lockjaw and stuff that
like she was there is no chance well you
know I appreciate your candor and just
being able to share
and I know that you you've chosen places
to to bring it up and you've logged
about it extensively and you please
don't kill yourself video that you made
and even as you know it was extremely
powerful to see you be that vulnerable
in that video and to honestly process
even in kind of a meta way the fact that
you were making the video and I found it
to be extremely powerful and honest that
you not only were talking about it but
you were talking about talking about it
because there's so many questions
associated with what you know presenting
this to to your audience or to the
Internet at large as it was uploading I
read the I found myself reading the
description that evidently you were
writing as the video is uploading what
you seem to still be processing kind of
like journaling just a stream of
consciousness with the vlog as it was
uploading wrestling with how people
might perceive you speaking about it and
then I keep reading down and you read
the comments and it's you know it's it's
extremely powerful and effective in
getting people to pause and to think
about it at no point is it easy to talk
about and I even feel I'm you know I
appreciate your candor here but it's
even getting you to talk about it now
getting you to go back to a place where
you've all that has to be so painful
that you've been on you've gone on
record that you know I I find myself
having the same dialog that I think you
had when you've logged the thing is it
should should we even talk about this
should I bring this up is it to benefit
anyone hmm
so I guess I just summarized and
resonate I with your struggle and so how
much is that defines who you are as a
person and as a as a person who blogs a
communicator a creator oh god like
percent like that moment is my
before-and-after like before my sister
committed suicide I could not talk to
people I was so shy like if I had to use
the bathroom someplace I would like
whisper to my brother and my sister like
please find out where the bathroom is
and like I'd always wanted to perform
but it was like crippling I was like
I'll never do that I'll never be able to
be that kind of person and Christina was
the complete opposite she was fearless
like I love this story that like in
middle school every year she would go in
the talent show with her friends and she
would choreograph a dance and every year
everyone would bail and so she would go
up on the stage and do that whole
choreographed dance by herself and at a
certain point it was just like these
friends of yours but like how fearless
and like brave of you to do and so after
she died I'd say like maybe two or three
years after that like I really realized
like there's no point and really being
afraid because death was finally
something that I felt like I really
understood and in that sense of like we
really don't know what's after this so I
might as well try to make this the best
that it can be for me and it feels like
kind of cliche of like yeah just gave me
perspective and now I'm going to be a
comedian but ultimately I think it's the
best and the worst thing that's ever
happened in my life wherever a sense
that because she Cristina you said was
her name yes was a she was a performer
and she was she was fearless that now
that she was gone it was kind of your
job to sort of take that up what's her
sense of that well all three of us had
always wanted to be performers since we
were young it was like a very common
thing like we shared and so we'd like
perform for each other with each other
but definitely when she died it was this
pressure of like oh I have to do it for
the both of us now and I think she would
she would be happy with it you know like
I finally just started to do stand-up
about it
it's taken me seven years but I'm like
okay how can I try to make this funny
like that's the ultimate parks I
couldn't I could not laugh about it for
the longest time and anytime someone
said in the conversation like oh if I
had to sit in traffic for one more hour
I'd kill myself it would just it would
set me off for like hearing people the
way we use suicide in common language
but now I'm okay and now I can crack
jokes about it and that's that's what I
feel like has been the most healing was
there
I mean guilt that you had to deal with
there oh yeah well I mean I was the last
one to talk to her and I was like I hate
you go away forever so it there appear
ially helped in your vlog you say
everywhere you turn it's there meaning
that the fact that she took her own life
you said I'm a different person I don't
know if it's for the better or for the
worse
and I mean these are not key this is
obviously from the heart you're just
kind of processing this thing do you
know if it's for the better or the worse
is it I don't but I try to consciously
make it for the better
how are you a different person um I'm a
different in the sense that I'm no
longer afraid of a lot of the stuff that
I used to be afraid of
I am I go after what I want more I kind
of tried to take every thing that I have
and make it work for me
and yeah it kind of it does kind of it's
like the filter through which a lot of
my decisions are made and do you
remember how your how did it change
everybody else oh how did it change your
parents how did it change your brother
well your relationship with them and
we've never been like a close-knit
family like dinner would be ready and
we'd all get our dinner and go to our
rooms like my parents are very hardcore
gamers so they would always be in from
the computer Sega Genesis or whatever
and me my brother would be off on our
own space and so after she died that
kind of exacerbated it brought us
together briefly but then we all kind of
like went to go process our grief on our
own and now it's now it's much different
and I'm able to be like completely
honest with my parents without the fear
of judgment or without the fear that
they'll get angry with me and I mean I
dropped out of college even though they
didn't want me to and moved out here
despite their protests and even though
they were like well are you sure you
don't want to go to college and get a
degree into it uh they were still happy
with my decision and so my pair
seems to be very typical Asian parents
like uptight and get an education and
get a good job but after this happened
they sort of realized like no we just
want you to be happy like we we realize
that there's a lot of stuff that we've
been doing wrong and so we just want you
guys to go do what you want and we will
support you and be supportive of that
so do you remember the first thing that
you know as you were processing you said
it took two or three years yeah it seems
like it led you to that change that it
occurred it within you is what led you
to where you're at right now so do you
remember the first sort of application
of that change like I'm going to go and
perform in this way or yeah I it was
like think two years after she died I
was watching a Comedy Central special
and it was the first time I had laughed
in those two years and so I was like I'm
gonna go do stand-up and so I pursued
stand up from like 19 to 22 what was the
special do you remember that it was a
compilation it was like Gabriel Iglesias
and Margaret Cho and they had some Mitch
Hedberg up in there it was just I
watched it I think for a couple hours
and I just I fell in love with how much
I was laughing I was like I want to do
that I can do that and you where were
you living at the time I'd Sur macula
California okay mm-hmm very boring very
small so what did you do specifically I
started writing jokes and a notebook and
recalling everything funny that I
thought had never happened in my life
and then I booked a show my first time I
went up I had eight minutes it was very
weird because normally you'll do an open
mic when you start out with like three
minutes but I had an eight-minute set
and all my friends came out and my
parents came out and the first time they
saw me do stand-up was when they've
really started to get it and we're like
oh no go ahead leave college oh really
yeah so that was the first as you said
I'm leaving college to do comedy before
you had ever done one stand-up yeah okay
a self-fulfilling prophecy here your
parents bought in and that's when you
just moved do you move with anybody just
rent a high school friend and I moved in
together with my three cats we lived in
Marina del Rey mm-hmm yeah and then what
I did comedy for a few years
XJ no-cost stand-up comedy and then I
started doing a bunch of web series
and then I got a very crippling social
anxiety so I quit stand up for like
three years but I went back in it so
what what what happened was there
something that precipitated it
specifically I don't know it was like
the better my set got the more and more
worried I was and I can't really explain
what it was it was just like this
unexplainable angst of like knowing oh
my god I'm gonna be on stage tomorrow
like I should leave town I should tell
them my grandma died and like cancel the
show and I think it was just like having
never gone to therapy to like deal with
all my it was that building up so it
wasn't that you fell flat on your face
an embarrassment it was within your mind
yeah and it was a little bit self
sabotaging like sometimes I would make
decisions that would purposefully lead
me down a dark road because of the guilt
and like this feeling of like oh no I
shouldn't be allowed to succeed so would
you just you wouldn't show up at things
or you just said I'm not booking things
anymore I just completely stopped doing
it so once my last show was up I like
didn't book any more shows and I like
didn't go to any more open mics and I
just stopped for three years yeah and so
what happened in those three years did
you stay here YouTube okay because I was
like I can be home alone
I don't be with anyone I can just make
videos in my house so interesting
because that the transition from you
know sort of getting into stand-up
comedy and then moving to YouTube is is
that's happened several times more than
more than a few times but usually it's
people being in front of an audience in
a you know Chinese restaurant or
someplace where you why am i doing
stand-up here you're like why am i doing
this for 20 people when I could be doing
it for 20,000 people on the internet for
you interestingly it was I am
intimidated by this and I have a social
anxiety about this this group of people
that I'm seeing so I'm gonna go on the
internet where more people will see me
but I'm more comfortable in a yeah with
my surroundings I can deal with the
troll you know but I couldn't deal with
like a bunch of people smiling at me at
a show right so let's come back to
YouTube but let's skip ahead to going
back onstage for the first time through
years later yeah what was that like um
I'd been wanting to do stand-up again
for a year or so I like had the itch and
I was like I think because I ran away
from that I should go back to it and I
should confront it and I started writing
again so I wrote like a bunch of like
suicide jokes and it's taking me a lot
of open mics to like figure out where
the punch lines are cuz and it's still a
little bit wonky because people don't
know that it's okay to laugh like it
takes them like three or four jokes and
to be like okay I'm allowed to laugh
with you with this but it's been great
I'm like it's funny because now I'm like
I made a video that a hundred thousand
people saw this morning like this bar
full of four peoples nothing and so it's
been fun to like go from a two-hour line
of people wanting to take a picture to
like going to a bar and like drinking
alone till it's my turn to go on you
know do you get backlash for the suicide
jokes like I mean do you mention your
story specifically or is it I just
isolated from that you're talking to
it's very personal what's stand-up like
the more personal it is somehow the more
relatable it is so you get blowback at
that point not the audience can you yeah
how could you exploit that experience
for laughs yeah I've heard that online
but I've created jokes to like address
it and also it's like this weird thing
of like no you should feel worse about
the terrible thing that happened you you
shouldn't get over this
stop making light of this tragic event
so I don't take it personally I'm like
that's if you can't see what I'm doing
on stage that's your own problem with
your own life but no one has confronted
you face to face about it correct found
that interesting in a good way that well
I find it fascinating that it fits the
profile of a troll that yeah and and
maybe there's a there's actual when
you're there in the room it conveys in
such a way that people get it yeah and
you know it's slowly but surely the more
confident you get in your jokes
I'm sure if you pass around papers
someone who still say something like a
jerk but they're you know if they don't
have to sign their name - right pass
around some little comment shape sheets
of paper you should try that actually
are you they could give you the
thumbs-up or thumbs-down drive to the
stage okay well we can't talk about your
YouTube without talking about
raywilliamjohnson okay how do we talk
about ray just tell us you tell us how
do we talk about
you can tell I'm can if I can't say
anything I won't say anything you know
but I'm open to talking about it start
at the beginning Ray and I met in 2012
at a showcase and I think I'd met him
once before that I was like a hoe on
breaking for like one of my friends was
like I need someone just to be in a
pretty dress and come down and do this
for like an hour so I did it for her and
then we let her met and then we started
dating and I think like three months
later we like moved in together
so when you say showcase he met at a
showcase this is a stand up it's a
sketch it was a sketch showcase for CBS
okay for them to be like we're not
racist look at all these people of color
on our stage yeah yeah and he was just
in the audience know the VP of casting
for an Ornstein invited him because her
sons were fans of him and so she watched
him and she was like oh this kids really
funny so she brought him into the
showcase versus like the rest of us were
like auditioning to try to get into the
showcase he was an invitation judge but
he performed yes and in this guy in one
of the sketches several of them yeah we
were all in like several different ones
so what was your first interaction with
him did you know did you know him from
him equals three no not really I wasn't
savvy to the Internet and I'd like only
ever seen my episode of Breaking so I
was like I don't understand what what
this is like I didn't realize it was a
vlog versus like a show or anything like
that because I was merely at the time
putting stuff up on YouTube I wasn't I
didn't know it was a full-time job I
didn't know there were vloggers I didn't
know there were sketch teams on it and
so we kind of got together and my sketch
group fell apart and he was like you
should keep making videos under your own
name just learn how to clone yourself
and like keep making sketches and so
that's kind of what I started doing so
you were on he you started your channel
because he encouraged you to do it mhm
and but you weren't on his channel for a
while but you met in three months you
you you started dating immediately and
three months later you guys were
like real serious living together yeah
starting to show up in instagrams
yeah those type of things we started
working together much later cuz he was
very tentative about working with the
partner and like doing stuff with with
someone you're romantically involved
with what how would you describe Rey's
reputation publicly like what people
think of Rey and then what's right and
what's what's wrong about that dispel
some myths I have the opposite so I knew
him personally before I ever saw equals
3 and so Rey in person was always like a
very serious and like somber and like
hardworking and like quiet man and then
I saw his persona on equals 3 and I was
just like laughing so hard cuz like you
seem like such a dick on the show and
that's not you at all and my parents
actually didn't want me to date him
because that's all they had seen of him
and it wasn't till they met him in
person that they were like oh we get it
this is like kind of like a persona or a
character so a lot of the times like it
was weird to have to tell people like
he's playing a character you know that
right because he's so convincing and I
was told himhe I was like you have face
you just have that face that people are
like you look like so it kind of like
helped that persona but it sucked for
him because people would think he was
like that
did you feel like you had to clarify
that obviously you had to clarify with
your parents yeah did you have a little
bit of a chip on your shoulder when it
came to friends and people that found
out you were dating him yeah people
didn't who did not know him and who only
saw his content on the internet had an
opinion of him and I had to constantly
be like that is not who he is he's a
generous hard-working very kind person
that's a character but it was also
really interesting because a lot of my
friends who thought that were actors and
like did have characters so it was like
why can't you get it you know right yeah
something lost in the genre yeah yes a
YouTube video right the presentation is
that this guy's being himself and he's
just talking about videos so I could get
that mm-hmm right it's a it's a quick
assumption but it I wouldn't say it's
fair but it's it's an easy assumption
absolutely and it might be a safe
assumption giving
given the breadth of like I'll say
vloggers yeah you know when did you
begin to experience internet hate
because I'm sure that came as soon as
the very first time you appeared in
anything publicly yeah he was like find
your voice make a video however often
you're gonna make a video and then once
I like kind of nailed what I felt like
my thing was he started promoting me and
yeah people were just like uh Beutel uh
[Laughter]
and it used to like really bug me and
that's when I kind of got it cuz he used
to like get upset about trolls or be
like why do people like hate me so much
you know which is a very natural thing
to feel when you get a lot of hate on
the internet and I would be like it
doesn't matter they're not a part of
your life don't let it get to you and
then when it's at you it's like oh god
this is a totally different feeling it's
so easy for me to say one thing but feel
the other and so it's been a constant
battle but you were so you were learning
the ropes of this mm-hmm
and he was at the top of YouTube at the
same time yeah so you were there for
yeah and he was very but my impression
was that he you know he had a tendency
to isolate himself mm-hmm like he I mean
he wasn't you know whenever you show up
at YouTube events or like you never meet
ray yeah like he was he was an island
and still is he had a lot of social
anxiety so crowds he didn't like to do
like any kind of social event he got
very anxious about it and it's something
that he dealt with it
in his own way but yeah it was this
weird and accessible thing but also like
primary primarily I think he's a
producer and an actor and so he already
experienced a lot of biased for in the
traditional world being like oh no
you're that guy in the Internet you're
that guy who does stuff in your bedroom
and didn't want to perpetuate that and
you were the the lead in Riley rewind
which was his first correct me if I'm
wrong but the first for Ray
his channel into something that didn't
feature him yes I mean now you see he's
he's basically not on there he's not the
face of his channel anymore
I think Riley ryona was the first thing
right yeah it was certainly I mean that
was a collaborative effort initially
between you two initially I wrote it for
my channel because I was like I want to
do scripted like at that point I had
kind of a significant following but
everyone didn't believe I was an actress
or a stand-up comedian and so I was like
oh that makes sense I have to put stuff
on the internet that I want to be seen
as so I wrote it and he really liked it
and was like I'll produce this like I
want to produce stuff and I'll direct it
and so that was our first real
collaborative effort of bringing
something narrative I mean YouTube and
how did you guys make the decision to
put it on his channel was that the once
he saw it and liked it he was like we'll
we'll put this on equals three yeah yeah
he he he sunk a lot of money into it and
he was like I want it to have the best
possible chance of getting a lot of
views and maybe we can sell it to
television so we'll put on my channel
and how was that process of
collaborating it was good I mean we had
a lot of a lot of tough things happen on
that shoot and a lot of like the budget
was missing and like a lot of the people
on board we were like what's happening
there's all these miscommunications but
ultimately we were really happy with how
it turned out and then you you also
collaborated in a number of different
ways you guys did a podcast together and
I mean you you know you became a youtube
poop lick power couple yeah I mean I
like working with the person I'm with
it's just how I especially in this
industry when you're on set for like 12
hours a day like why wouldn't I want to
be with my partner on set for 12 hours a
day so it was something that I was
always on board with and something that
I kind of pushed ultimately but I like
to I mean I don't have any regrets
though the collaborations that you were
pushing that yeah I mean did you either
a feel like the first lady of YouTube
when he because he's at number one yeah
or resent people treating you that way
it was a little bit of both you know
like it was great because any questions
I had he could answer and give like
really good business advice on and so it
was it was this nice
relationship of being able to talk out
stuff business-wise but then again it
would suck because I would have people
come out of the woodwork who would like
try to contact me to get through to me
to get to him or we would go to places
and people like push me out of the way
to like get to him and so it was a
little bit both so were you behind the
controversial tweets to like make her
and stuff like that say here let me let
me handle that for you know I encouraged
it because a lot of stuff happened
behind the scenes that never made it
public publicly and it was at a point
where I was like you're going to get
completely screwed unless you do
something so I did support that decision
and why'd you guys break up um I think
power dynamics I mean as you said he was
at the top of YouTube and I was at the
bottom you know I I and I feel like now
that I'm at that kind of I'm not at the
top of it but I'm at a place where I'm
successful like I would be kind of like
weary of someone wanting to work with me
and like maybe question their motives or
something like that and I mean he
sustained me financially like helped me
quit my waitressing job so that I could
pursue stuff creatively and did a lot
for me but I think ultimately I was more
like the Robin to his Batman and then
the Superman to his Batman are you guys
still friends well we haven't talked I
mean I how did it end
oh we it was kind of mutual we both
decided to just cut off all contact and
and go our separate ways and you so no
contact sense yeah so that was just the
agreement the agreement wasn't it wasn't
I hate you I'm never talking to you
again it was like this is how we're
going to do this we're going to do this
write it we don't talk to each other
anymore yeah I mean I was kind of like
the girl about it I would call him and
then be like I don't want to do this
anymore like be my friend and then it
was just like no take it over each other
like you have to go away so that's how
it's been and shortly after that no well
I mean basically when it happened you
were pretty public about the fact that
you guys had broken up you know because
people find out that kind of stuff
anyway so you kind of owned up to it and
then he private it like we can't you
can't see the podcast where you guys
were together
no it's on iTunes and I get that you
know like sometimes to get over someone
especially in the Internet's like
someone tweets
about him everyday or like I see several
comments it's hard to get over someone
if if you're constantly reminded of them
right so I get that and you but you also
made essentially a public Val you're
like I'm gonna be single for a year and
you talk about this in the sure you talk
about it more than once but I saw it in
at least you're the Dan'l Daniel
Radcliffe video why'd you do it I had a
friend who did it and I thought it was
really cool and so I wanted to present
the extremist side because I also knew I
was gonna do that Daniel Radcliffe video
so it was a strategic move of being like
I'm gonna publicly announce this
extremist point of view and then I'm
going to do the follow-up with the
Daniel Radcliffe video of Daniel
Radcliffe telling me to stop being an
extremist because I have been a serial
monogamist and then bowing to be single
I thought was the complete opposite of
that and so I was like I want to present
both of those sides in different videos
and then I want to have the somewhere to
meet in the middle with freaking Harry
Potter did you literally have a ring
yeah okay had you had you did your
friend do that same thing to do the ring
part the ring part was a joke but she
actually did I didn't see that video
what's the ring that's Lord of the Rings
not Harry Potter I'm confused no like I
bought myself a wedding ring I was like
I'm single for a year so I'm married to
myself oh and did that did you notice
that that worked in public like a guy
would come up to you and he like he
would see the ring and you would back
off did it have its intended effect
really I didn't wear it for that long I
would wear it for fun out in public to
be like whatever but no but it didn't
you didn't make it a year no I never
intended to okay yeah I was always like
I'll just go with the flow and whatever
happens and then you met Brad yeah yeah
how did that happen
Brad was the he runs a couple of shows
at nerdmelt at meltdown comics and he
was the host first show that me and my
friend Megan Rosati we do comedy songs
together live so we did a song there and
that in they've been longtime friends so
that's how I was introduced to him okay
and you know it's interesting I was
gonna ask you this question I'm still
gonna ask you the question but then you
you specifically said something that
kind of speaks to it
and talking about your the reason you
broke up with Ray being the power
dynamics and it's kind of reversed in
the in this situation right and that's
you know and when it comes to the public
perception of you and your success and
then if you're just talking about
YouTube into you know independently
you know Brad's getting his footing on
YouTube he's doing a lot of stuff with
you he's Robin to your Batman so what
what what is how does that dynamic
different now that she's on the other
foot I think he does so much live comedy
and that's kind of what I wanted to get
more into when we had met and so it was
this great aspect of like him wanting to
do more video and me wanting to do more
live comedy and I think I don't think of
our power dynamics as uneven because
he's such a good character actor who
comes from like a Groundlings background
and is like so talented in that regard
and very capable like I was surprised
most men aren't very organized at least
the ones that I've met and he's
incredibly like organized and thoughtful
in that sense I mean I am I'm are
successful in terms of like online yes
am I more financially stable yes but I I
also know how to avoid any kind of like
weird power high jinks because of my
previous relationship and so now if I'm
like oh maybe we shouldn't do this
because I don't want it to affect how I
see you or how you how equal we are in
this partner give us an example um like
okay like he has a web series and he
wanted me to act in it and I was like
well am I gonna be all but how obligated
my to promote this and so you know cuz
this is the thing I mean our promotion
is kind of our power online and so he
would be like I don't expect you to
promote it in any way whatsoever and so
I was like cool and so went going why do
you want to promote it explain that I do
but I don't want to be cast because of
that and so I I just I like now I'm on a
binge of like if anything comes up just
ask just clarify just be as honest and
pop as possible and like express my
worries or my concerns and that's been
very beneficial and so anytime I feel
like that's gonna happen or like what
whether we do a podcast as well explain
things to me which is like educational
side rice or science stuff and so I'd be
like well what's our role in this like
if I'm fronting all of the money to get
it started how are you
going to contribute are you doing all
the editing are you doing all the
producing and so we make sure going into
everything that we feel like we're both
equal equal yeah and so what's the
what's the Equality split well how do
you what how do you divide that up for
say the podcast for the podcast like I
front all the money for it he takes care
of all of the di t he takes care of all
the editing he also works in conjunction
with my assistant to make sure
everything is produced correctly and so
we both feel like we're contributing
equally to this project unless it's
something that we agree oh you're the
boss on this one and I'll be the boss on
the next one and how much conflict is
happening because because you've made in
order to promote the podcast you made a
comedic vlog where you kind of it was
tongue-in-cheek you were kind of a
tyrant yeah so you kind of hit it head
on yeah the audience perception of oh
she's working with her boyfriend yeah
again yeah and she's you were making fun
of yourself of like being in charge yeah
I mean that's just who I am as a person
I'm always not like bossy but very
assertive and very like no I want to do
things I want to do them right
so I why is that not bossy I just don't
like the word or you're really not bossy
I think the word bossy is so negative I
don't I don't like the connotation of
bossy because it's just feminism and
yeah so I don't know our main conflict
comes from me being really grumpy and
like Brad having to bear the brunt of me
being cranky but he's very calm and like
chill I'm like no it's cool you're a
human being I get it
okay so so he he can he can take it
yeah we weathers the storms yes it's
like you know I'm fire and he's like
sand and you are I mean you're doing so
many things now you know you're the
podcast the your channel talking about a
movie you've got the pilot auditions
yeah yeah and sundry series what's that
called a craft lab craft lab so all
types of stuff uh are you you feel like
you're doing too much
sometimes yeah sometimes yes especially
because I'm also in all the improv
schools right now and like on two
different improv teams I'm like
constantly trying to make more sketch
but I really like working really like it
so I'll keep probably so what what's
your how does that impact personal
health like you seem to be pretty
healthy and happy yeah I am I try to
make enough time to like take care of
myself you know and like hang out with
friends like make sure I get that one
night off a week where I can just stay
in bed and like watch a bunch of Netflix
so to make sure I don't become too much
of a workaholic I also put stuff on my
task list schedule of like make sure you
get lunch with a friend this week or
make sure you like chill for an hour but
if you had to choose is it the film that
you talked about at the top is it is it
landing the role and then in the sitcom
that you're auditioning for in pilot
season you know if you did have the
power to decide what the big thing was
what would it be it would definitely be
landing a steady acting gig like in a
great TV show or a movie but I would
probably still do all the other stuff on
top of that but you would your ultimate
passion interestingly because you said
at the top that you have to use two
different parts of your brain for
directing and acting that means if you
had to make that choice you would be
doing the exercising the acting muscle
yeah definitely it's the most fun it's
the least amount of responsibility on
set everyone is so nice to you yeah and
you're usually not paying for it you're
getting paid yes that's it that's a nice
thing yeah that's great I mean producing
your own stuff is amazing as well but it
is so much work that once in a while it
would be nice to act and then go into a
trailer and write and then go back on
stage and act you know right yeah all
that downtime is Brad honey how do you
think he is dealt with your success
because you kind of talked about how you
see him and the things that he's done
well what is it like a what how is your
relationship with him you're like okay I
remember what it was like when I was
with Ray and
he got recognized Brad is an anomaly he
is the only person I will ever know who
like peaked in high school but keeps
peeking in life you know what I mean
like like the one word to describe him
would just be kind
he's like best friends with a very
successful screenwriter and like knows
everyone in this town but is never
jealous of anyone success he'll get
jealous if someone has like a really
good idea or a really good character but
he's everyone who knows him is like he
is such a supportive and helpful and
generous person so he wants you to get
that acting yeah he's so supportive like
he would he wants to go to VidCon and
just like hang out the whole time and
I'm like wouldn't you be bored like
sitting next to me for two hours at a
signing he's like no man I think that's
great I just wanna watch you meet your
fans I think that's amazing
so he's a very very special person it
sounds like you're in a great place and
we're super happy for you people are
gonna tweet at you afterward okay and
what do you what do you you probably
need to go ahead and tell you tell them
what to not tweet about the race stuff
I'd prefer if people didn't because it
would make my life easier yeah yeah
sorry we had to bring it up that's okay
it's a podcast I expected to talk about
everything did we miss anything
no suicide and relationships and and
great work high-quality work on the unit
Angus
so yeah we're fans and thanks for
hanging out with us let us get to know
you
[Music]
and there you have our ear biscuit with
Anna Akana tweets at Anna using hashtag
ear biscuits let her know what you think
of the conversation
I always appreciate when I look through
the hash tag ear biscuits I search by
that and I just I love only search
Twitter by that only I love it when I
see that you guys are talking back to
our guests and they come back up to us
and say you know I'm still hearing about
my episode on air biscuits and it's
meaningful to them so it makes a
difference they see it we see it Anna
will see it her twitter handle is Anna
Akana lots of 80s and lots of ends in 1k
a double na a ka na that's three four
five that's five days Wow three ends one
you only kick in any random order well
no no specific order
Anna is a great example of somebody who
took a very difficult circumstance in
her life and turned it into a positive
and I'm always inspired by that because
when you experience something traumatic
when you experience something that's
incredibly difficult
those are crossroads in people's lives
and you know it's interesting we get to
talk to a lot of people who have
accomplished a lot you know we're
talking to people who've done a lot in
the entertainment industry and mostly
the YouTube industry for every Anna
there's somebody who let an event define
them in a negative way I think that
should be encouraging for people out
there who are going through something
difficult that even as something as
difficult as your little sister
committing suicide which is a horrific
thing that you would never wish on
anyone
it's a crossroads in your life and it's
up to you to how are you going to react
to that and how are you going to deal
with that are you gonna let it define
you in a negative way are you gonna let
are you gonna ultimately overcome that
and you know let it define you in a
positive way and there's no track for
that I can't prescribe that I had that
kind of thing happen to me right but you
can look at somebody like
her as an example of light you can she's
never gonna there's no doubt she's ever
gonna get over she's never to her over
it but it can you know she's
incorporated into her story which she's
moving she's moving forward with it yeah
it's part of who she is and you know I
think I from a lot of your biscuits you
see plenty of successful great people
who have overcome or who have dealt with
or who are still carrying some some
hardship or some level of adversity that
I can't even imagine so that's I counted
a privilege to be able to have these
conversations I'll go up I'll add
something to Anna's story you know I
really wanted to dig in to the specifics
of her vlog please don't kill yourself
because she spoke there were so many
things happening it's such an it wasn't
that she had dealt with something and
then she put it out there as an example
she she put out there the honest place
that she was that I mean this is this
was six years after the event and it was
still extremely painful but she was
being raw and honest and having the
conflict in the in the video with
herself
and conflict with herself in the
description as the video was uploading
to figure out it just to deal with how
she communicates and how she talks about
it and so I'm extremely encouraged that
just her honest way that she just put
that out there in that vlog people
responded to it and that's one of the
instrumental ways that she became a
positive example anise and a light to
other people when it comes to suicide
prevention but she you could tell that
she it was not calculated no you know
she was afraid that it was gonna be seen
as a calculation in the other direction
like a calculation for views she she you
know she said their consecration because
there are little any of people who would
do who would do that I'm just grateful
that she decided to post it anyway and
that she was completely honest there's
you know I think about if something
horrible were to happen to me I have it
you know we have a connection with our
fans but like
how would we deal you know I would I'd
want to you know my instinct would be to
be very private for a certain amount of
time but at a certain point do you just
present how you processed it or do you
let the people who know you through the
internet become get window into the
process itself that's an interesting
interesting because we don't use we
don't use our platforms that we have
like would give it the good morning or
really even your biscuits as an
opportunity to tell you like when we
talk about stuff more personal stuff in
good mythical more but it's still kind
of light-hearted I mean that's we that's
a decision that we've we've made to be
like we're going to tell you about ten
people who had their stomachs or
whatever I'm not saying that it would be
a path that we would need to take I'm
just observing that when she chose to do
that even though I don't know that she
fully realized the impact and the way
that that vlog would come across that
there was a power in processing it
honestly and not having all the answers
or not have landed somewhere but just
putting that out there
yeah and that was extremely powerful
yeah and I appreciate her coming on here
and talking candidly even more about
that and other things thanks again to
Anna and thanks to you here biscuits
here for listening and hopefully you
will be back again next week because you
know what we will we'll be here making a
biscuit
[Music]
[Music]